he probably doesn't have a wife anymore
yeah this guy sounds like a single dad
he doesn't have custody anymore yeah I
don't think he has custody of the child
this is a weekend visit bro
did you guys hear about this story in
Florida
where there was a car that was just
sinking into a canal
and there was inside the car there was a
toddler oh no yeah
and so
they all of a sudden like the police
show up cars in there sinking right and
the driver just couldn't get his kid out
of there
so he like bails out right and then he's
like ah [__] I gotta get my kid right oh
[__]
he forgets me he's like I forgot the
girls I forgot something yeah and then
but then he looks the window open oh
right my kid's in there that's the son
of a gun of a thing
important important yeah and then so
then the the guy is also like I don't
want to get my shoes wet whoa so then
the cops dude wet socks is the worst
it's pretty bad it's really bad it's
horrible before we move forward let's
have some empathy for this guy okay he's
freaking out yeah bro his car what kind
of car was it Steve
um Hyundai Elantra it doesn't say it's a
Lamborghini yeah yeah dude he's gonna
get his car ruined 20 G's down the drain
and then it sucks do your socks and the
used car Market's wild right now yeah
dude yeah you can't buy a new car in
this market ever since carvana went down
yeah
damn can't get it off a vending machine
no more so by the cop by the time the
cops get there the guy is just sort of
Milling around the car right because he
just doesn't know what he's just pacing
he's looking he's like oh [__] yeah and
so the cop one of the cops is like [__]
it
the barrier the point of entry was
taking your shoes off yeah he takes his
shoes off any Asian there would have
dominated the situation they'd be like
oh no problem take my shoes off in the
shoes is that that's what stopped him
that's exactly why is that really what
it is crazy do you think he should still
be a parent do you think he should give
his kid away for that well he might have
had like Doc Martens on and he goes I
can't do it with it
what kind of shoes maybe maybe did he
hit were they like the dark Martins on
yeah they were suede did he have feet
were they Prosthetics he's pretty pumped
it was either it was either uh alligator
like very expensive yeah or some Gucci
it was Heavy alligators live in water
no they were actually Crocs but he
didn't know their water
[Laughter]
no they were Reebok Pumps that were just
too filled they were taking forever it
would have floated after
his legs
now they're just flotation devices so
after the police arrived after the
police arrived they couldn't really see
through the water at this point so the
car's underwater the car's underwater
the kid is still in there
unbuckle I know dumb ass kids that
teacher can't unbuckle like that's the
fastest thing that kids learn how to do
is get the [__] out of the seat
dude that's fine but like then you just
gotta bust open the door but isn't it
really hard to open up a door it's water
it's being pushed it's slightly harder
it's really hard how do you live with
yourself knowing that you're a little
[__] yeah that's the thing your son or
a good shot you're like I can't take my
shoes my kid died because you couldn't
save them because you're like I don't
know about the kids
that too boys
if I was that if I was the dad I would
never admit that like I didn't want to
get my socks wet I would never
say that to say that to the Press dude
to say that to Fox News guy you think
the police officer was like it doesn't
make sense I did all these [__]
microphones in front of him he's like I
just didn't want to get myself
frostbite frostbite maybe we're the
weird ones and everyone else accepts it
like oh yeah it's very brave of you yeah
you can't get your socks wet police
officer pulls on the door and after
trying many times he has to keep coming
back up for air he pulls as hard as he
could he eventually gets the door open
he pulls the kid out of the car seat
passes the kid to an emergency crew and
they start doing wow oh [__] and then
the kid goes [__] you Dad wait the the
kid wait water got into the car already
or yeah water was it was submerged yeah
I saw the picture it's [__] it was
submerged that Hyundai Elantra you
destroyed huh when it's like that I'm
like how do people get in there because
I'm assuming the water is like probably
murky like how do you see it you know
you gotta feel it Braille your way dude
yeah underwater Braille so so do you
think the dad is like mad that he got
cooked out by this cop he actually got a
shoe deal he got dad I can understand
that no he um because his socks get wet
I mean he's probably wearing those
Champions that are really thick yeah and
they're expensive and they get soggy
yeah yeah you might sink to the bottom
what was it making you buy when you're
trying to dude that's why I'm wearing
shoes I'm wearing waterproof shoes those
are waterproof these are ones these are
the guys shoes
oh man the leather joints yeah that
makes more sense damn dude they were
they weren't treated yet
the dough you know what it is they
weren't treated yeah think about those
shoes how long do you think it took them
to tie them up so to take them off
sit down he's got to pull the laces
and they'll never be the same if they're
they'll never be is this person now
going to jail for leaving their kid in
the car no isn't that a thing though
like you can't do that abandonment yeah
well technically it didn't abandon the
vehicle he was just sort of Milling
around it he just he was like I'm just
gonna watch it all go down I'm gonna be
an eyewitness to everything was this you
secured the perimeter
he was making sure that there was North
yeah yeah the flooding was consistent
maybe he was afraid that there was a
crocodile swimming in the water he was
like where the [__] was he parking yeah
what was his Florida this was in Florida
by a canal some reason I thought it was
here when all the floods were going down
no I didn't know um Californians they
would have [__] done it huh yeah I
don't know yeah yeah yeah yeah the
officer who saved the kids life
said that once the kids started
breathing again he started crying oh and
then the officer started crying too
because it was the best Cry he's ever
heard in his life
[Laughter]
I mean you know knowing us this is going
to turn dark in about five seconds
and the dad was like [__] man what am I
gonna tell my wife oh she's pretty much
he probably doesn't have a wife anymore
yeah this guy sounds like a single dad
he doesn't have custody anymore yeah I
don't think he has custody of the child
I've never seen those comments this is a
weekend visit bro
you guys ever see you guys ever seen
those compilations I love the dad saves
oh yeah yeah the baseball right I saw
one that's the opposite the kid no like
the dad will [__] hold the dad fails
and then like a guy would be with his
wife or whatever walking down and the
guy comes up and then he pushes his
[__] wife and I was like what the
[__] oh my God I gotta find it it's a
smart move it was the funniest one but
that's basically this dude it's the
reverse dad saves yeah so there was a
car accident that's why they were in the
canal by the way also they hit something
and they just went bunk but then it was
the shoes afterwards that episode then
it was the shoes that was the major wait
he was in a car accident so did the car
fall into the river he wasn't wet like
now now none of this makes sense he
wasn't wet he bailed he bailed out yeah
yeah you know like in GTA when you jump
out like oh you jump he jumped out of
the moving vehicle the child then jumps
off the bridge like oh [__] my vehicle
because the kid didn't get the timing of
when to roll out of it
you remember like um several years ago
there was uh he thought he had a prodigy
you got to do a reenactment
yeah remember that like pre-covered
right there was always like Texas was
flooded and [__] there's foot there's a
there's a video out there on YouTube
where you can watch this happening where
this car is like [__] going in and it
just starts submerging right and then a
guy comes in that he just [__] swims
up I don't know if he was like a fireman
or a paramedic or whatever and he goes
down opens the door he gets back up gets
air goes back and he pulls somebody out
whoa what a gangster was he a [__]
Navy SEAL did you start laughing at some
point because you saw like people
getting stranded on the floor no I saw a
team of people he's like people dying I
love it
funniest have mine yeah what the [__] is
that a bunch of firemen that are like
nine going in there because my socks I
know you have not noticed them I always
could change you bro yeah but wait what
what's in that cup bro can't turn healed
you guys see that on JK news the other
day just just today when can turn people
yeah do you love disaster videos don't
you you're one of them Lively kind of
dudes
Kane was a baby face
the whole time I was like what the [__]
that's when he blew up though which one
we should start our own wrestling
faction that's a good idea dude it's the
attitude Aaron in this room oh yeah all
the time baby can't start the revolution
dude I thought we were starting
something new for 2023. well it didn't
started yet were those people who were
gonna start something no what's uh
what's up we're Perpetual Gunners yeah
2022 was Attitude Era no it still no it
never left baby
[Laughter]
what's the actual definition of an era
then is that like a collection of years
yeah it's a period of time yeah
it could go forever like a decade it's
ten yeah yeah but it could be an era the
Renaissance Era one year
it did it everything was done in one day
when you study art history it's the same
just one year and then it was Baroque
right after whatever
I don't know I'm just making [__] up
dude
[Music]